Hello Peter
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new spider-man no way home marvel video they
just released a couple of new scenes with doctor
octopus they also confirmed sandman in a slightly
different way so i'll explain that and we also
just learned this amazing story about andrew
garfield's amazing spider-man 3 movie that they
almost wound up making that involves kevin feige
in this really crazy marvel retreat to try and
come up with a way to convince sony to let them
make the next spider-man movie so if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos there is a brand new spiderman no way
home trailer that's going to be coming really soon
too of course i'll be doing all the videos for
that stuff i'll start with a brand new spiderman
no way home scenes they release then i'll talk
about the crazy andrew garfield story if you
missed the news or you didn't see it all over your
feeds marvel did a brand new preview of spiderman
no way home a couple days ago and as part of
that they released a couple of new scenes both
of them involve alfred molina's doctor octopus
from the tobey maguire spider-man movies it's
a couple different scenes but you only actually
see him in one of the scenes the first scene is a
little more obvious just because of the context it
kind of links up with some of the trailer footage
we've seen before this is happening during the
extended spider-man vs doctor octopus fight scene
taking place on the george washington bridge where
he's wearing the iron spider suit in the trailer
alfred molina's doctor octopus says hello peter
as if he recognizes this peter parker even though
it's tom holland's peter parker and even though he
doesn't really look like tobey maguire he kind of
looks like him from a distance and he's wearing a
suit this exact same suit toby maguire was wearing
during spider-man 3. so they're trying to make
tom holland look as much like tobey maguire as
possible without literally photoshopping his face
onto tom holland's face most of you have probably
seen the memes people have been posting about
this just because it's kind of a funny scene with
spider-man turning and running away from doctor
octopus whereas normally you'd expect spider-man
to be web slinging away this is not the first time
that spider-man has been caught running away from
one of his villains they did all the way during
the first toby maguire spider-man movie where he's
running away from the green goblin you also notice
that he doesn't have his iron spider legs anymore
so the fight makes a little more sense now it's
probably happening a little bit earlier in the
film like it's not part of any big final battle or
anything like that and it's just meant to be a big
boss level villain upgrade fight where spider-man
gets his ass kicked and has to upgrade his new
spider-man suit and by having doctor octopus
just hand him his ass so easily it makes him
seem like much more of a threat in the movie but
then spider-man has to go to ground and develop
some new strategies for fighting doctor octopus's
abilities with his arms and obviously there are
all the other sinister six villains with their
different abilities too spider-man will have to
evolve his fighting techniques that's usually the
main reason why he gets all the new suits in each
new movie is that the suits are tuned for whatever
the villain's abilities are like that's why he's
probably wearing the black suit which looks
kind of like the anti-shock suit combined with
the anti-aux suit from spider-man ps4 and why he
needs the addition of doctor strange's magic tied
to that black suit but if you didn't realize too
the reason why they're using the george washington
bridge for this fighting in particular is the
same bridge that spider-man and mj get caught
on by that police helicopter before everybody gets
hauled in for questioning at the beginning of the
movie if you're not from new york city or you're
not familiar with the landscape of manhattan the
george washington bridge connects manhattan and
queens spider-man and mj both live in queens so
it's like he's being caught by everyone including
doctor octopus when he's trying to go home
but this scene of them getting caught on the
bridge is before doctor strange's spell and before
doctor octopus and the other multiverse sinister
six characters get brought to earth just denoted
by the different suits that spider-man is wearing
when the fight is happening and based on the way
they play this scene in the trailer like when the
fight begins and you see doctor octopus's arms
come in and he greets peter hello peter spider-man
suits up in the iron spider suit he's thinking
to himself that he's upgraded to the iron spider
because it's the most advanced most hardcore suit
that he has he just used it during avengers end
game in the big final battle it's got the greatest
defenses it's got the greatest weapons the instant
kill mode on it is also way more hardcore than the
instant kill mode from the advanced suit or the
original stark tech suit so if it worked so well
against thanos army how could one dude with eight
arms be worse than thanos's army thus spider-man's
overconfidence leading to him getting his ass
handed to him and them making doctor octopus
come off as being way more of a threat and unless
they're pulling some tricks on us here with the
way they edited this trailer the way this fight
scene with him goes down on the bridge it also
seems like doctor octopus is either using willem
dafoe green goblins pumpkin bombs in the fight or
if they're playing tricks on us there could be
multiple villains in this fight marvel has done
that all the time in the past just messed with
footage like the avengers infinity war trailer the
avengers end game trailer just to mislead you so
that you don't know what's actually happening in a
fight and doctor octopus probably just makes quick
work of his iron spider suit just ripping all the
peters iron spider legs right off of it after
which spider-man is like oh and then just turns
around and starts hauling ass away and they're
just playing this is a funny moment because the
bridge that he's on doesn't really have anything
for him to swing off of so he has to literally run
you also probably remember during spider-man
homecoming they used this funny twist with him
literally having to run across the golf course
because it was nothing for him to swing off of
this sucks the other new scene that they released
as part of this preview is of spider-man in the
advanced suit they're just calling the new steve
ditko red and black suit the advanced suit now
he's gone back to that suit he's not wearing
the mask he's all bloodied up and he's in the
middle of a different fight with probably
doctor octopus the reason why i think this
is doctor octopus he's fighting crouched down
in this fighting stance is because if you look
closely at the metal platform that is standing
on zoom and enhance it looks exactly like
doctor octopus's fusion reaction platform from
spider-man 2. the last time we saw him in that
movie he had pushed the platform into the east
river and was sinking with it down to the bottom
alfred molina kind of gave away or spoiled
the doctor octopus plot the beginning of
spiderman no way home however you want to
think about it kevin feige was not amused
he said that the story of his doctor octopus and
spiderman no way home begins right after he went
into the river at the end of spider-man 2. like
for him when spider-man no way home picks up it
will be as if no time has passed for him at all
that's why he's wearing the exact same trench
coat he looks the exact same they're using special
effects to de-age him almost 20 years to make him
look the exact same but all the patterns the
structures on this fusion platform just look
the exact same as the structures spiderman is
standing on so when doctor strange's spell to
make everyone forget peter parker's spider-man
starts working and he starts weaving together
aspects of alternate timelines alternate universes
also inadvertently bringing all the sinister six
characters from the tobey maguire spider-man
movies and the andrew garfield spider-man movies
and doctor octopus legit shows up inside the mcu
doctor strange probably just accidentally brought
his fusion platform with him when they released
these new scenes tom holland also did this special
interview where he previewed the special new
mystery character that they haven't announced
in the film yet he said some of his favorite
scenes to film in the movie were with this
new special mystery character i actually think
that he's talking about andrew garfield spider-man
because he's talking about having dinner with aunt
may with happy hogan and this mystery character
now the conversation they're having is about
what it means to be a superhero and that just
seems like the way they would use andrew garfield
and toby mcguire's spider-man characters in the
movie helping tom hans peter parker spider-man
understand what it really means to be spider-man
the other really cool thing that they just
did on the sly was kind of confirmed sandman
with one of these big covers so if you look at the
artwork here you can actually see what looks like
sandman's hand rising out of all this sinister six
art we've all seen the trailer a billion times and
i think we're all in agreement that this figure
here that's forming here this earth that's coming
together isn't a giant dust cloud it's actually
sandman forming into a giant face it's just
that during this fight spider-man also seems like
he's fighting jamie foxx's electro because of the
yellow lightning and he's also wearing the black
suit too there's supposed to be a new spider-man
no way home trailer soon they'll either release
it with the eternals movie real soon or later
in november with the sony ghostbusters movie but
during that new footage we'll probably get more
legit sinister six characters and it will give us
more context for how they're all coming together
and what's really going on john watts the director
said that behind the scenes at marvel they're
calling the movie spider-man end game because
it's so big in scope like what did avengers end
game mean for the infinity saga of movies this
is the same thing but for the spider-man movies
i just did a separate spider-man video where tom
holland was kind of explaining how this was going
to work like if we come back and we do more movies
it'll be completely different vibe a completely
different story i'll add a link for that video
at the end of this and down in the description
but the crazy andrew garfield amazing spider-man
3 story that you've probably seen in the past
day or so is all part of this big marvel history
book so this is history book they publish about
the history of marvel studios and it tells all
these behind the scenes stories about what was
happening when they were trying to make all these
movies the past 10 plus years and obviously a big
portion of it focuses on them bringing spider-man
into the mcu because that was such a big deal
the story goes that back in 2014 when sony was
getting ready to make amazing spider-man 3 with
andrew garfield and their separate sinister
six movie kevin feige held a special retreat
for the marvel studios people where they tried
to come up with a way to convince sony to let
them have the spider-man character like what
can we do to stop them from making amazing
spider-man 3 and convince them to let us make a
new spider-man movie that's completely different
it sounds totally crazy but obviously the rest is
history we know how that all played out they wound
up getting the spider-man character and making
all these movies with sony but as soon as they
release more spider-man no way home footage of
course i'll do a brand new video or if you have
any big questions that you want me to answer in
bonus videos just let me know in the comments
everyone click here for my marvel eternals
movie review and click here for that new
spider-man no way home sinister 6 video and to
learn about the future of spider-man in the mcu
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!